the chairman of the premier league gary
hoffman is on the brink of resigning uh
amid the backlash from many of the
premier league's clubs uh about the
league's handling of the takeover of
newcastle united remember about a month
ago that takeover long-awaited takeover
protracted negotiations
finally went through in a 305 million
pounds deal led by saudi arabia's
sovereign wealth fund the league faced
intense criticism in the aftermath of
that announcement uh from a number of
the clubs who felt uh that they had been
blindsided by the fact that the deal was
finally going through and i understand
that mr hoffman who only took up the
role uh of chairman of the premier
league just under 18 months ago
is
about to resign could happen in the next
few days now mr hoffman is a heavyweight
figure in the business world uh and he's
had a huge uh hugely intensive in trade
to deal with during his short stint at
the premier league remember last year uh
project big picture which was the reform
plan table by liverpool and manchester
united that would have seen uh the
premier league number of premier league
clubs cut from 20 to 18. that was seen
off there was of course the huge
disruption uh both financially and in a
sporting sense to the premier league uh
by the outbreak of the coronavirus uh
pandemic and then of course more
recently we had the uh
bombshell announcement confirmation that
six of the premier league's clubs
including uh arsenal chelsea manchester
united and liverpool were going to
join a european super league that
confirmation came back in april the
project imploded after less than 48
hours and the clubs that had agreed to
participate uh would then find
significant sums or agreed to pay
significant sums in supplements to the
premier league as a result of their
decision uh to join that super league
now uh mr hoffman according to one of my
sources
has been left rather carrying the cam
for the decision uh to approve the
newcastle deal but in reality according
to many of those who have been briefed
on the the details of those negotiations
over many months uh the league did have
little choice in the m but to approve
that deal
going through as i say sarah jane an
announcement about gary hoffman's
resignation is likely to be made in the
next few days